I'm feeling really upset and frustrated
about Steph's jealousy problem and had
lack of intimacy with me in always is
really messing with my head I'm sorry
that I'm not like handhold II and you
know it's like just because I haven't
given you more affection in like 3-4
days of knowing you I feel like you've
excommunicated me you know like you keep
like referring back to the fact that
we've only like being half like a couple
of days or whatever what about those
whole month we were like romantic then
and now I'm like you know I want someone
to be excited about I want someone to be
excited about like being around me
[Music]
until like hold me and kiss me and like
it's just the zooming cold ascent stuff
it hurts
ergo starts telling me how I'm not being
physical enough with her and it's really
upsetting to me
I don't want Erica to think that I'm not
attracted to her but I haven't been
intimate with somebody in over a year I
feel like I really truly need to trust
somebody before I let them in that way
there's a difference between talking
about things online and then meeting and
being thrust into a new situation like I
just met you and on top of that I'm
meeting all these people and I'm like
you don't want to do anything you don't
want to you're saying I like meeting new
people as hard you're saying that mean
planning dates is hard literally
everything is too much like why did you
even go Mia why like why bother stuff if
you can't be affectionate if you don't
want to meet my friends really sorry
like I feel like hey so I'm really sorry
like I but I don't know what I could do
right now
[Music]